come on you gutless cowards I have a
come and get her
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones this will be a
very quick update video about some
filming news from one of the sets in
Northern Ireland to some of you this may
not seem that significant but I
personally think this is very
interesting because it does confirm one
reunion in season 8 this video will
contain spoilers so please proceed with
caution but according to one of Watchers
on the walls very reliable sources they
have spotted Theon Greyjoy and Yara
Greyjoy filming some scenes together
they have been filming this week in
Bainbridge Northern Ireland filming
studios the set they are using contains
a ship and a giant green screen and this
is one that Game of Thrones regularly
uses whenever they need to film scenes
on a ship while they were there they did
spot Fionna and Yara together shooting
some scenes with some other Ironborn
followers as well they do not have a ton
of details about any particular scene
they were shooting but this does confirm
two things
Theon will reach Yara and they will see
each other again before either one of
them dies euron greyjoy was not spotted
on the set that day but that does not
mean he will not be involved in these
scenes but at least we know Theon and
Yara will get to see each other one last
time this does open up a lot of
speculation though because you have to
wonder where the healthy on will find
Yara
the last time we saw Yura was in King's
Landing during season 7 episode 3 when
Euron brought Cersei her gifts after
Euron handed over the sand snakes we did
not see Yara again but we did see your
own at the dragon pit in the season 7
finale
according to Cersei Lannister she sent
Euron to pick up the golden company but
that doesn't necessarily mean your ax is
with him for all we know Yara could be
locked up on the Iron Islands
that would make it a hell of a lot
easier for Theon to rescue her if he
could get there while you're on is off
gallivanting around the world picking up
the golden company but if your ax is
locked up on the silence with your on
this will make it pretty tough for Theon
to get our back
Theon only has a crew of about 20 men
the only good thing about having a
smaller crew is it's easier to sneak up
on someone but I do have a feeling Yara
will be at the Iron Islands in Theon
will have to make a very similar
rescue attempt as Yura did when she
tried to free Theon from Ramses but
there are a number of different ways
this could go down but at least we know
urine won't kill Yara before Theon can
get there and at least we know Theon
won't die before he sees her again the
details are still pretty vague but we
know for a fact they will meet again
hopefully Theon can save her without
getting either one of them killed but
we're gonna have to wait and see I'm not
gonna speculate too much about this news
because I already did make a prediction
video about Fionna and Yara but leave me
some comments and let me know how you
think this is gonna play out where do
you think Theon will find Yara and do
you think they will be able to get away
from your land without either one of
them dying let me know your thoughts on
this and if any other news comes out I
will be sure to keep you all up to date
make sure you subscribe and turn those
notifications on that way you can be
alerted as soon as I upload a video I
would greatly appreciate that before I
go I just want to make sure everyone is
aware of the giveaway I'm doing I have
one more copy of Game of Thrones season
7 on blu-ray with the bonus disc about
the conquest and rebellion I will be
picking the winner on Christmas Day so
make sure you enter the giveaway now
that way you get a chance at winning
this there are five different ways to
enter that will increase your odds of
winning good luck everyone and thank you
for stopping by
to watch the video I also want to thank
my patreon supporters before I go I
really appreciate everyone's support
especially during the holidays it really
means a lot to me I hope everyone has a
happy holidays I will see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]